we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i received a
voicemail about what at least one caller
believes is the undoubted future
re-election of president donald trump
let's take a listen to it I don't
support Trump but I'm pretty confident
he's likely to get reelected if things
are as they are now in 2020
I mean as much as the left likes to say
the economy is terrible it's really not
and I don't think a lot of people buy
these arguments that the left is making
that the economy is so bad his poll
numbers continue to increase and I don't
think the left has any idea how to
oppose them yeah
the poll numbers are sort of just
between 38 and 40 percent I'm not seeing
any kind of steady increase but I
actually am very worried that the caller
is correct humans suffer from a
cognitive bias called peak and bias
which is that they will often make
decisions about a lot of things as to
how it ended this includes a medical
procedure if it ended not being that bad
even if it was really bad for the first
80% people's recollection of it will
often be of it not being that bad the
same thing happens with the election or
re-election of presidents where there
will be a significant focus in deciding
whether to vote for re-election or not
on the last six months or even the last
12 months if there's a good economy in
the last 12 months people will often
forget or sort of block out or not
consider everything that happened during
the first three years or three and a
half years I think that there is a lot
to that and I I've been saying it Pat
I've been saying it that the solution is
to vote the people out that are doing
the horrible things and I'm worried it's
not gonna happen in November and I'm
worried it's not going to happen happen
in 2020 either it's hard to predict this
far out that's for sure but I would say
it's maybe 50/50 right now sure a lot of
people hate Trump but he has a lot of
sycophantic supporters too and the last
three presidents got their reelection
run so as a general sense there's power
of incumbency like put Trump put Trump
totally aside for a second there's the
power of incumbency there's the power of
raising more money we know that in
American
politics the candidate who raises more
money overwhelmingly tends to win and
then of course you have some of these
other biases and heuristics that people
like Daniel Kahneman have pointed out to
us so I am extraordinarily concerned
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about former or FBI
agents Peter struck formerly of the
Robert Muller investigation being
escorted out of FBI headquarters we will
talk about a very interesting study
related to confirmation bias and facts
versus opinion and I also want to talk
about this Ted Cruz Jimmy Kimmel charity
basketball one on one match that they
played and I get that it was in a sense
literally fun and games it was a game of
basketball after all but I'm a little
bit disgusted with some elements of it
all of those stories and more on the
bonus show sign up at WWE at medCom
or make a pledge at patreon.com slash
david pakman show